so i'm over seven on the woke
commercials and i've told the producers
i say i want to get this right
so give me a clue and then maybe i'll be
able to get it a little more correct
we've got two commercials here in the
genre of white guilt so they're
specifically
woke on the racial issues hopefully
that's going to narrow it down for me
i'll be able to guess
what product these woke commercials are
actually
selling let's roll the tape
okay
[Music]
could be a car right you see the car
there is
very prominent like a mercedes or
something
[Music]
oh yeah that's what always happens white
guys and elevators just like your
clothes
i hate i don't want to be in an elevator
with a black guy yeah
[Music]
yeah man white guys are so bad they just
go wherever they want yeah
hate them
you know they like get out of pools
because they don't like swimming with
other other people and stuff
[Music]
it looks
[Music]
a wedding thing or a
i guess a courtroom
he's the judge but you thought he wasn't
the judge
you thought he was not respectable but
he is the judge
education i'm going to say it's
something with education that's what
it's selling
let's talk about the look so we can see
beyond it
[Music]
procter and gamble
[Music]
not even close i thought because the
whole thing was ridiculous that you know
basically
every basically everyone's just really
overtly mean and nasty to black people
all the time in america you know that's
that's totally what happens right not
that every single restaurant has like
blm
please we love you please you know not
no it's not like that
um but i thought it had to be like an
i because the education would have at
least had some tie-in right because it's
like and then i became a judge
but but no it's proctor and gamble
no no connection whatsoever i'm going to
try one more
but as painful as this experience is
watching these commercials an even more
painful experience is paying too much
for cable if you're fed up with paying
high cable prices
and dealing with extremely shady cable
companies there's finally an alternative
that gives you the cable tv experience
at
drum roll please half the price actually
half the price
it's called fubo tv fubo tv comes with
over
100 of your favorite channels including
complete coverage of all your favorite
sports with all local broadcasters
nfl red zone espn abc cbs a whole lot
more
you can stream select games in 4k plus
you can record your favorite games and
shows
on fubotv's cloud dvr and watch it
anywhere
on any device it takes just two minutes
to sign up and start streaming
all your favorite cable channels no
cable box required it's no hassle it's
great they're terrific
sign up for a risk-free seven-day trial
of fubotv get 15 percent off your first
month
by going to fubotv.com knowles fubo
tv.com
noel start your free trial get 15 off
now let's see if i can win
this challenge to guess the woke
commercials i was so off on the procter
gamble thing
are there any other can i get any other
hints no no other hints okay
roll the tape i will pay extra close
attention i will turn my
leftist woke radar on to pick up on all
the little details what is it
who said that the lady at the store
that is not a compliment it's an ugly
nasty word
and you are going to hear it nothing i
can do about that
but you are not going to let that word
hurt you was it like the n word i guess
because yeah that's what happens all the
time right white people just always
calling black guys the n word all the
time
yeah the only time you actually hear the
n-word by the way is in rap music
yeah that's it over you getting a ticket
this is about you not coming home oh
yeah racist cops just uh
slaughter innocent black people all over
the country you know that of course
that's what always happens
i mean statistically it doesn't
let's talk about the talk racist cops
uh uh the procter and gamble again ah i
should have guessed that because it's
just like there was
no tie-in to
ev to any like company there there was
no tie-in to any product procter
gamble what does procter gamble have to
do with any of that
do you guys have any idea no no not at
all
not not at all okay well that wasn't
fair because i just assumed i was like
well this is like a similar commercial
but
it couldn't be the same company so
that's not fair i'm
i guess i'm o for nine but i'm going to
count that as like oh for eight and a
half
try again next time send in send in your
woke commercials i want before i
end this series i want to get one of
them right so just please send in your
commerce make a little easier next time
hopefully i can figure it out we'll see
you then